[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous Bienvenue
c'est Science Publique votre rendez-vous
quotidien de débat de reportage et
d'expertise sur Public Sénat et c'est
une émission au cœur de l'actualité que
je vous propose ce soir avec pour
commencer une ministre sur le grill de
la commission d'enquête du Sénat Marlène
Schiappa a dû répondre pendant trois
heures aux questions sur le fond
Marianne créé après l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty et destiné à lutter contre
la radicalisation en ligne y a-t-il eu
détournement de fonds publics certaines
des associations financées par ce fond
Marianne ont-elles attaqué des opposants
d'Emmanuel Macron pendant la campagne
présidentielle en en débat dans une
minute et puis notre second débat actu
nous mènera en Ukraine et en Russie
puisque nous allons détailler le rôle de
la milice Wagner sur la ligne de front
face à la contre-offensive menée par
Kiev Wagner et son chef est gagné
Prigogine qui continue d'attaquer le
ministre russe de la Défense
les tentatives du ministère de la
défense des Hulk aurait la situation
dans le champ informationnel mène et
mèneront à une tragédie globale pour la
Russie
immédiatement arrêter de mentir si vous
vous enfuyez construisez de nouvelles
lignes de défense
qui a créé ce groupe Wagner quels sont
ces liens avec Vladimir Poutine quelles
horreur ces soldats ont commis en
Ukraine mais aussi en Syrie ou au Mali
ne ratez pas les explications de nos
experts dans trois quarts d'heure mais
d'abord une ministre face à des
sénateurs décidés à comprendre où sont
passés les deux millions cinq cent mille
euros à louer au fond Marianne pour bien
comprendre les enjeux de cette audition
Rémy Renaud parquet pardon remonte aux
origines de la faire
faute d'avoir convaincu elle a au moins
pu s'expliquer aujourd'hui devant la
commission d'enquête du Sénat concernant
la gestion du fond Marianne car cela
fait trois mois que Marlène Schiappa est
au cœur de cet engrenage politique au
judiciaire elle récuse toute forme de
favoritisme en faveur de l'association
quadministrée par Mohammed Tifaoui l'US
Open je ne suis pas une amie de Monsieur
Sifaoui je n'ai aucune relation
personnelle d'aucune sorte avec Monsieur
cifaoui et je n'en ai jamais eu exit
aussi toute volonté de sa part de
refuser à SOS Racisme une dotation de
100.000 euros on me prête beaucoup de
relations personnelles mais je n'ai pas
de relation personnelle ni de désaccord
personnel ancien ou récent avec monsieur
le Président de SOS racistes retour sur
la création d'un fonds semé d'embûches
six mois après l'assassinat du
professeur d'histoire-géographie Samuel
Paty en octobre 2020 la ministre en
charge de la citoyenneté de l'époque
propose un plan pour lutter contre les
séparatistes
je lance un fond qui s'appellera le fond
Marianne avec 2,5 millions d'euros on
peut faire beaucoup de choses pour
défendre les valeurs de la République et
l'objectif du fond Marianne doté d'une
enveloppe de 2 millions 500.000 euros
consiste à soutenir des actions en ligne
à portée nationale à destination des
jeunes de 12 à 25 ans exposé aux
idéologies séparatistes qui fracturent
la cohésion nationale et abîme la
citoyenneté au total 17 associations
sont donc choisis par le comité
interministériel de la prévention de la
délinquance et de la radicalisation en
charge de gérer le fond Marianne mais le
30 mars dernier deux enquêtes
journalistiques de France 2 et Marianne
révèlent que seulement quatre
associations se partagent la moitié de
la notation le parquet national
financier ouvre alors une information
judiciaire le 4 mai dernier sur la base
des enquêtes journalistiques pour
détournement de fonds au cœur du fond
Marianne plusieurs irrégularités
apparaissent d'abord
l'uspm co-dérigé par Mohamed Sifaoui
elle aurait touché 350 000 euros pour la
production de vidéos peu vue sur
Internet et le versement de 120000 euros
de salaire aux deux exigeants un rapport
de l'Inspection générale de
l'administration pointe alors plusieurs
dysfonctionnements l'appel à projet n'a
été ni transparent ni équitable
l'utilisation faite de la subvention
reçue par l'uspm n'était pas conforme
aux objectifs fixés
le secrétariat général du cipdr n'a pas
accompli les diligences nécessaires
directement mis en cause le préfet
Gravel démissionne le 6 juin dernier
autre association en ligne de mire
reconstruire le commun selon Médiapart
l'association dotée d'une enveloppe de
330 000 € aurait diffusé des vidéos sur
les réseaux sociaux si blanc directement
des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle comme Jean-Luc Mélenchon
ou encore Anne Hidalgo demain Mohamed
Sifaoui sera auditionné au Sénat
l'épisode du fond Marianne n'a pas fini
d'empoisonner Marlène Schiappa à l'heure
où des rumeurs de remaniement
ministériel plane
et pour débattre de cette audition
j'accueillerie mi-ferrot bonsoir
bienvenue enceinte sénateur socialiste
de Paris et secrétaire de la commission
des finances vous avez assisté à
l'audition de de la ministre Hélène
Salvi bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
vous êtes journaliste responsable du
pôle politique à Mediapart vous avez
enquêté sur sur ce dossier Jean garrigue
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes historien
président du Comité d'histoire
parlementaire auteur de Élisée contre
Matignon le couple infernal livre publié
chez Talandier et Mathieu croissanto
comme chaque jeudi comme chaque mardi
est à mes côtés éditoris politique
bonsoir Mathieu bonsoir bienvenue à vous
je rappelle quelques chiffres qu'on a eu
en partie quelques infos qu'on a eu en
partie dans le sujet d'ouverture il y
avait donc deux millions cinq cent mille
euros à louer pour lutter contre la
radicalisation en ligne 71 associations
avec candidaté 17 ont été sélectionnés
et puis vous l'avez entendu dans notre
reportage deux d'entre elles posent
question
l'Union des sociétés d'éducation
physique et le préparation militaire et
l'association reconstruire le commun on
a posé le décor Rémi Féraud après
l'audition de Marlène Schiappa est-ce
que vous parlez toujours de détournement
de fonds publics c'est une expression
que vous aviez en loyer avant cette
audition oui mais je le dis toujours
d'ailleurs je crois que c'est pour cela
qu'il y a une enquête judiciaire qui est
ouverte donc c'est bien pour
détournement de fonds publics notamment
à l'évidence et votre reportage juste
avant le montrer une partie de l'argent
du fond Marianne a été détournée de son
objet qui était la lutte contre la
radicalisation des tournées de son objet
à un tel point qui est la même pu
participer à une forme de populisme
ambiant par un certain nombre de vidéos
que nous avons vu qui ciblaient en
particulier les candidats de gauche à
l'élection à l'élection présidentielle
donc il y a
la présomption de détournement de fonds
publics il y a une enquête judiciaire
mais le travail de la commission
d'enquête parlementaire du Sénat
aujourd'hui et plus large que cela sur
l'ensemble de ce qui a pu conduire à
cette situation actuelle quand j'étais
venu sur le plateau de public Senna il y
a quelques semaines pour dire que
c'était grave il y avait un peu de
scepticisme cette commission d'enquête
montre qu'il y avait besoin absolument
de d'aller plus loin dans les
investigations et qu'on était bien dans
le cadre d'une affaire grave et on aura
évidemment dans ce débat l'occasion de
détailler un certain nombre des des
faits qui sont reprochés à Marlène
Schiappa et plus généralement dans le
cas de l'utilisation de ce fond Marianne
elle a une salisse ce matin la ministre
elle a pas varié de sa ligne de défense
qui consiste à quoi renvoyer la balle
vers son cabinet c'est ce que vous avez
retenu vous de ces trois heures
d'audition oui version cabinet et vers
absolument tout le monde en fait était
responsable ce matin la presse son
cabinet son ancienne administration mais
absolument pas Marlène Schiappa ce qui
est assez étonnant dans cette histoire
c'est que
il y a beaucoup de contradictions entre
les différentes auditions entre celles
du préfet Gravel entre celle de l'ancien
directeur de Marlène Schiappa la semaine
dernière et évidemment avec celle de la
de la ministre ce matin beaucoup de
contradictions de chronologie qui ont
été pointés notamment par les
questionnements des sénateurs lors de
l'audition de Marlène shabbat ce matin
des encore plein de questions je crois
que le rapporteur de la commission
d'enquête a dit au terme de votre
édition qui a quand même duré trois
heures il reste beaucoup de questions en
suspens et je pense que c'est le cas
effectivement et que le rapport et les
différentes enquêtes qui sont ouvertes
sont destinés à les à y répondre mais
rien n'a été
éclaircie sinon
finalement des encore de nouvelles
contradictions c'est plutôt ça que je
retiens Jean garrigue
le sénateur fait on disait la gravité de
cette affaire selon lui comment vous
l'évaluez vous cette gravité alors ça
c'est compliqué je pense que la
l'expression détournement de fonds
publics doit être manié peut-être si je
peux me permettre avec un tout petit peu
plus de précaution parce que forcément
si l'on manie cette c'est imputation et
on l'a on l'impute forcément à la
ministre or manifestement même si elle
est responsable de légèreté et peut-être
même de favoritisme à l'égard d'un
certain nombre d'associations qui ont
été choisis s'il y a eu des tournants de
fonds publics il me semble que vous
voulez dire qu'il y a eu utilisation de
ces fonds par certaines de ces
associations à des fins qui n'étaient
pas celles prévues par le cahier des
charges c'est plutôt ça à mon sens que
que vous visez si vous parlez de
détournement de fonds publics une
accusation qui est grave et dans
l'histoire quand il y a eu des
détournements de fonds publics les
conséquences politiques ont pu être très
très grave aussi donc je pense que là
dessus il faut être très très précis il
y a plusieurs sujets il y a le sujet de
la manière effectuer à la va-vite la
sélection d'un certain nombre de
d'associations à subventionner il y a la
manière dont ou non la ministre est
intervenue dans ce choix qui devait
appartenir un comité de sélection mais
dans lequel siège trois membres de son
de son cabinet et puis il y a le choix
lui-même de ces associations était-elle
destinée ou pas à remplir ces fonctions
et puis elle contrôle de l'argent qu'il
aurait pu la louer et puis
il y a le contrôle de ce de cet argent
manifestement le suivi a pas été fait
correctement ce qui a pu donner lieu à
un certain nombre d'abus mais ça y est
c'est là encore faut être très précis
parce que quand vous parlez des de ces
vidéos qui ont été faites à l'encontre
de de leaders de la gauche il me semble
avoir lu mais je connais pas le dossier
et si vous connaissez certainement mieux
que moi mais il me semble avoir lu que
il y avait aussi des vidéos qui étaient
pas très tendres pour des gens de ce
qu'on appelle la macronie donc tout le
monde en prenait un peu pour son grade
alors ça veut pas dire dire que il faut
justifier ces vidéos là et qu'elles
étaient et qu'elles entraient dans le
cadre de ces de ce de ce cahier des
charges mais voilà je pense que il faut
en la matière être assez n'allons pas
trop besoin en faisant le lien Schiappa
et utilisation de cet argent dans le
cadre de la campagne
la parole ensuite de ces vidéos c'est
effectivement intéressant de connaître
le dossier en la matière parce que il y
a des vidéos qui ont concerné la
macronie j'aime pas beaucoup cette
expression mais voilà mais elles ne sont
pas du tout du même ordre c'est-à-dire
que les attaques politiques qui sont
faites contre des opposants et des
opposants d'Emmanuel Macron dans les
vidéos sont des attaques politiques
s'agissant des manuels Macron ou de
Marlène Schiappa en l'occurrence il est
question de sa coiffure ou de que
sais-je mais qui ne sont pas des des
attaques politiques première chose
deuxième chose le préfet Christian
Gravel lui-même a reconnu d'abord auprès
de Mediapart puis devant les sénateurs
que il avait
redresser la barre d'une certaine façon
en tout cas fait un rappel aux
responsables de cette association
reconstruire en commun or on a appris
lors de l'audition de la présidente de
l'association en question que
effectivement il y avait eu une sorte
d'échange un peu informel dit-elle entre
le préfet Gravel et elle-même à ce sujet
au sujet du caractère politique des
vidéos mais que cet échange de concerner
et je la cite que des blagues anti
Macron qui n'avaient visiblement pas été
comprise par l'administration donc en
fait on est vraiment dans un registre
politique oui mais alors juste une
question si ces attaques politiques
portaient sur la question de la plus la
souplesse on va dire vis-à-vis de
l'islamisme parce que du séparatisme ou
du communautarisme je veux dire par là
que si dans ces vidéos là il était
question de positionner une question que
je pose de positionnement puisqu'on
parle d'un Hidalgo de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
par rapport à l'islamisme aux
communautarisme là on était peut-être
dans
la terre en droit de de publier ces
vidéos et vous dites qu'on était
peut-être dans la mission d'origine oui
mais ça n'a aucun rapport avec la
réalité des vidéos alors moi j'en ai vu
un nombre elles sont dans le Hidalgo
bashing finalement assez classique
c'est-à-dire sur le vélo et le partage
de l'espace puis comme maire de Paris il
y en a même une à connotation xénophobe
par rapport à ses origines espagnoles ça
n'a rien à voir avec cela et je crois
qui compris les attaques contre Jean-Luc
Mélenchon n'ont rien à voir avec
l'islamisme la radicalisation ou même
les valeurs de la République donc
c'est pas que ça ne résume pas l'affaire
ces vidéos mais elles sont quand même
illustratives d'un problème d'un
problème que moi je ne minimise pas
comme trop rapidement pour vous c'est du
détournement de fonds publics
qui ont été utilisés je ne donne pas de
coupable d'ailleurs c'est pas le rôle de
la Commission
parce que ce sont des fonds publics qui
ont été votés pour lutter contre la
radicalisation à l'évidence ils n'ont
pas été utilisés à cette fin alors où
est le problème dans le cahier des
charges dans son absence dans le manque
de contrôle quels sont les
responsabilités
et on y vient à cette question et je
vous propose tout de suite d'accueillir
Jonathan Dupriez parce qu'on va assez
longuement et précisément bonsoir
Jonathan revenir sur l'audition donc de
Marlène Schiappa donc on l'a dit
commission d'enquête beaucoup de
questions des sénateurs qui l'ont mis
sur le grill pendant trois heures ouais
ils ne l'ont pas lâché d'une semaine
Marlène Schiappa et surtout pour
clarifier véritablement son rôle le quel
rôle exact elle a joué dans le cadre de
ce fond Marianne mais sénateur en vérité
ils veulent comprendre si elle a
favorisé ou non si elle est intervenue
ou non dans l'attribution de certaines
subventions assez 17 associations dont
vous parliez avec au total cette
enveloppe de 2,5 d'euros à répartir
ensuite et donc à maintes reprises et
bien Marlène Schiappa elle a semblé
beauté en touche la reporter tour à tour
la responsabilité sur son cabinet ou sur
l'administration en charge de distribuer
les crédits de ce fond et si elle a
reconnu tout de même quelques
dysfonctionnements et bien elle a
souvent tenté de minimiser son rôle
écouté le défausse pas
devant vous et j'entends endossé ma
responsabilité toute ma responsabilité
pardon pour la formulation mais aussi
rien que ma responsabilité
et les parlementaires ont passé pas mal
de temps sur le cœur du problème c'est à
dire l'attribution de la principale
subvention de ce fond Marianne oui vous
l'avez évoqué Thomas l'association
s'appelle
l'uspm elle a touché 250 000 euros sur
355 000 prévus et l'un des responsables
de la structure c'est Mohamed cifaoui
que certains connaissent sans doute un
essayisme franco-algérien alors lui n'a
pas été entendu par les sénateurs mais
il avait reconnu mi-avril je cite avoir
été encouragé par le cabinet de la
ministre et la ministre elle-même a
réclamé des subventions avant même la
création de ce fond Marianne et donc les
sénateurs et redoutent en quelque sorte
qu'on pourrait appeler un copinage de la
part de la secrétaire d'État envers
l'uspm et là encore elle s'est expliquée
à écouter je ne suis pas une amie de
Monsieur Sifaoui je n'ai aucune relation
personnelle d'aucune sorte avec Monsieur
cifaoui moi monsieur cifaoui je le vois
à plusieurs reprises et pas en tête à
tête et je tiens à le dire ici parce que
l'un un témoignage qui a été apporté
devant votre commission à affirmer que
j'aurai reçu personnellement en
tête-à-tête monsieur Sifaoui au mois de
mars et que ce serait à cette occasion
que je lui aurais annoncé qu'il aurait
une subvention ou qu'il serait éligible
au fond Marianne c'est faux elle a les
sénateurs ont également passé au crible
l'éventuelles implication de Marlène
Schiappa dans le retrait d'une
subvention cette fois-ci oui et là on
parle de l'association SOS Racisme le
comité de sélection du fond Marianne lui
avait attribué 100000 euros c'est une
association qui est bien connue des
Français mais c'est 100000 euros et bien
ils ont été retirés à posteri de cette
sélection et donc devant les sénateurs
il y a quelques jours l'ancien directeur
de cabinet de Marlène Schiappa il avait
reconnu qu'elle était personnellement
intervenue pour s'opposer à cette
subvention je cite en raison d'un
historique de relations assez anciens
c'est à dire en gros un différent
personnel et donc de son côté Marlène
Schiappa elle maintient toujours
fermement et bien qu'elle n'a pas
supprimé cette subvention la SOS Racisme
et au passage elle joue un peu sur les
mots écoutés je n'ai pas supprimé de
subventions à SOS Racisme je rappelle
qu'on est sur un appel à projet on parle
pas de financement ni de fonctionnement
pour les associations donc je n'enlève
pas de l'argent à SOS racisme dont il
bénéficierait chaque année
alors je vais je vais y revenir mais en
tout cas première élément oui
endroit vous avez raison c'est subtil
comme réponse je pense que le droit
emporte des explications qui n'ont pas
vraiment convaincu les sénateurs non et
d'ailleurs vous le venez de l'entendre
dans la teneur de ces échanges à de
multiples reprises les parlementaires se
sont agacés recadrons souvent une
ministre qui semblait un peu louvoyer
alors question elle a souvent elle a
souvent dit n'avoir aucun souvenir et à
tel point que ça a provoqué une certaine
ironie chez Claude rénale le président
de la commission d'enquête qui lui a
demandé un moment si elle oubliait quand
même pas dépend entier de sa propre vie
mais l'impression globale des sénateurs
c'est surtout que Marlène Schiappa à
l'Assemblée en fait se mettre à distance
d'un dossier qu'elle avait pourtant
porté à bout de bras écoutez Claude
rénale vous avez fait naître une idée un
concept une réponse politique et
derrière vous nous dites je la suis pas
c'est ça que vous venez de nous répondre
je vais vous le dire et c'est grave ça
vous nous dites c'est l'administration
l'administration est chargé de chez elle
est chargée de regarder que
financièrement les choses se passent
bien ça c'est pas votre problème mais
quand même le contenu les éléments
est-ce que ça sert à quelque chose
ça c'est vous quoi voilà Thomas est la
suite du feuilleton c'est demain
effectivement merci Jonathan avec
l'audition de Mohamed Sifaoui on en
parlait ce sera à suivre à 9 heures en
direct sur notre antenne je reviens vers
vous Rémy frérot sur sur justement cette
journée de demain et sur l'audition de
Mohamed cifaoui donc qui était l'un des
présidents de cette association
uspm qu'est-ce que vous chercherez à
comprendre demain précisément
je pense que le président et le
rapporteur de la commission avec
l'ensemble de la commission chercher à
comprendre qui a sollicité qui à quel
moment pour faire quoi qu'elle était
l'ordonnancement aussi de presque dans
le temps ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure des
sollicitations ou des propositions quel
est le dossier qu'il a proposé comment
s'est fait le choix il y a d'ailleurs
une contradiction entre Marlène siappa
et Christian Gravel sur ce même et
qui dit vrai comment les choses se sont
exactement passées donc c'est cela que
nous
chercherons à comprendre
la commission d'enquête c'est que le
rapporteur le président des éléments
dans leurs mains précis d'échanges de
mails de courrier voire
des échanges de messages c'est là où il
faut aller
les présidents d'associations peuvent
aussi montrer des contradictions entre
les déclarations les différents
responsables responsables publics
on l'a vu dans la chronique de Jonathan
Marlène Chappaz ce matin elle a dit ne
pas être ami avec Mohamed Tifaoui
qu'est-ce que vous savez vous de la
relation du niveau de proximité et
peut-être c'est le plus important
sur le montant alloué à cette
association est-ce qu'elle est
intervenue oui ou non qu'est-ce que vous
en savez en fait il y a deux choses la
première chose et c'est important de le
préciser c'est que toutes les personnes
qu'on entend là devant la commission
d'enquête on se positionner sous serment
ce qui veut dire que si elle monte elles
peuvent être poursuivies pénalement ça a
quand même son importance parce que
comme elle ne disent pas la même chose
il y a bien quelqu'un qui ne dit pas la
vérité au milieu la deuxième chose ce
qui était intéressant dans l'audition de
Marlène Schiappa ce matin c'est qu'il y
a au moins deux éléments qui viennent en
contradiction de sa défense principale à
savoir je n'ai jamais
mi le nez pardon pour l'expression je ne
suis jamais intervenu dans la sélection
des associations ou dans le choix des
associations bénéficiaire du fond
pourquoi deux éléments le premier c'est
celui que nous avons révélé justement la
semaine dernière dans la foulée de
l'audition du de l'ancien directeur de
cabinets de Marlène Schiappa à savoir
que oui après qu'une élection a été
sélectionnée par le communier de
sélection SOS Racisme Marlène Schiappa a
décidé de biffer pardon les 100.000
euros de subventions qui avaient été
accordée par donc trois membres de son
cabinet et trois membres de
l'administration première élément donc
ce qui marque une intervention
personnelle on peut appeler ça comme on
veut mais enfin ça s'appelle une
intervention personnelle deuxième
élément elle a elle-même produit devant
la commission d'enquête un mail qui date
du
6 avril si je ne m'abuse en tout cas
début avril c'est à dire bien avant que
il y ait la première réunion de
préparation du fond Marianne bien avant
son lancement officiel elle a produit un
mail dans lequel elle écrit
34 300000 euros pour l'association de
Mohammed cifaoui ça me paraît énormément
elle produit ce mail devant les
sénateurs pour expliquer j'imagine en
défense pour dire voyez je trouvais ça
je trouvais ce montant déjà excessif
d'accord mais on est avant le lancement
de l'opération avant même le lancement
de l'appel à projet de l'opération de
quoi parle-t-on quelle est cette
subvention en fait et à quel moment on
se dit que la ministre n'a jamais eu son
moi à dire dans les subventions qui ont
été accordées puisqu'elle fait ce mail
et au final il y aura 355000 euros à
louer je regarde que vous connaissez
assez bien mohamedifaoui qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de voilà de peut-être même
des attaques donc il fait l'objet alors
je le connais vraiment superficiellement
pour l'avoir croisé et discuter avec lui
sur des un certain nombre de plateaux de
télévision et pour avoir discuté en off
avec lui et mettre convaincu que ces
convictions laïques et républicaines
étaient sincères ça je il me semble que
je peux je peux en témoigner
pour le reste
c'est difficile de de porter un jugement
d'abord à la base moi je pense que
c'était une belle idée de d'avoir ce
fond Marianne pour défendre un certain
nombre de valeurs ça ça c'est clair et
je pense que il avait le s'était un de
ceux qui pouvait le profil pour porter
ses idées maintenant c'est évident que
la manière dont le dont le choix s'est
fait les les privilèges manifestent donc
à son association a pu bénéficier pose
un problème et effectivement met en
cause l'intervention personnelle de
Marlène Schiappa mais
jetons pas l'eau avec le bébé pardon
avec l'eau du bain parce que il y a
aussi beaucoup d'autres associations qui
étaient subventionnées certes de manière
moins généreuse mais qui sont
associations qui font vraiment un
travail très sérieux j'en connais
quelques unes comme Spirit watch etc qui
font vraiment un bon travail dans la
direction indiquée par abandonner la
lutte contre la radicalisation en ligne
je pense que c'est important je rappelle
aussi que Mohamed cifaoui alors pour
l'avoir croisé là aussi sur les plateaux
et quelqu'un qui vient en permanence
escorter par deux gardes du corps parce
qu'il est menacé de mort par les
islamistes donc je veux dire que c'est
quand même quelqu'un qui qui engagé dans
un dans un combat maintenant moi je suis
pas capable de vous dire que peut-être
il a été il a bénéficié de de de de trop
de subventions qui les a peut-être assez
mal utilisés ça c'est toujours les sons
travailler les enfants y intervenir je
trouve qu'il faut dézoomer quand même un
petit peu aussi se rappeler dans quel
contexte a été créé cette association on
l'a dit donc voilà l'assassinat de semer
le petit dans les conditions je vous
conseille derrière ça il y a quoi il y a
un geste politique et il y a de l'argent
donc il y a une volonté politique et il
y a des fonds et qu'est-ce qui est fait
de ça ce qu'on découvre aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on soulève le capot de la
machine et que c'est aussi indigent
qu'un descend et c'est
aussi un dysfonctionnement majeur du
système politique actuel je veux dire du
gouvernement de sur un projet qui est
aussi symbolique que celui-là de réussir
à faire un truc aussi barnum que ça à
dire c'est moi ce qui m'a sidéré
aujourd'hui dans le dans le dans
l'intervention de Marlène je sais pas
c'est que quand vous soulevez le moteur
de la machine Schiappa mais vous savez
pas où sont les tuyaux ni où sont les
vis rien ne tient les réunions c'est pas
quand elles ont eu lieu on ne sait pas
qui était on ne sait pas combien de
temps elles ont duré on sait à peine de
quoi on a discuté il y avait pas de
préparation il y avait pas de conclusion
enfin j'ai à tout éteindre l'avenant et
donc l'écran de fumée qu'on nous a servi
aujourd'hui montre à mon avis un
dysfonctionnement majeur politique sur
un sujet qui est essentiel parce que si
on jusqu'au bout ce qui doivent bien
rigoler aujourd'hui c'est précisément
les cibles de cette riposte républicaine
contre ce qu'on appelle le séparatisme
contre la radicalisation tous les
islamistes de tout poils qui veulent
faire vaciller les pays républicains ils
doivent bien se marrer en voyant le
résultat de cette gabgie et de sophiao
vous affirmez dans votre l'un de vos
articles de Mediapart que dans le vous
dit est fond politique dans dans cet
aspect de l'affaire dans le fond
politique de la faire il y a une
offensive de proche de Manuel Valls
auprès d'Emmanuel Macron c'est quoi
cette offensive de parler en fait c'est
une enquête qu'on avait menée des 2017
enfin qu'on avait mené que j'avais mené
dès 2017 à Mediapart quand j'étais en
charge de l'exécutif pour le journal
parce que j'avais compris en
m'entretenant avec différentes personnes
notamment dans l'entourage d'Emmanuel
Macron ça sortait pas de ma tête que il
y avait des personnes quand je dis
l'entourage proche c'est ce sont des
personnes en fait notamment autour du
printemps républicain des personnes dont
on sait les co-fondateurs de du
printemps républicain et sont des
proches de Manuel Valls Mohamed syfaoui
a travaillé avec lui pendant une
campagne voilà on sait que ce sont des
personnes qui voilà intellectuellement
et de logiquement politiquement j'en
sais rien appeler ça comme vous voulez
son proches de l'ancien Premier ministre
ce qui était intéressant c'est que à
l'époque en 2017 quand Emmanuel Macron
est élu il est élu aussi en opposition à
Manuel Valls sur la question de la
laïcité il le dit sur le plateau
Mediapart en novembre 2016 il dit s'il
est là ici c'est son expression gagne en
mes prochains alors nous aurons perdu
collectivement le combat il parle à ce
moment-là de Manuel Valls et de cette
sphère là de cet écosystème politique là
et il va même plus loin il dit ne parle
pas quand il parle de laïcité il ne
parle pas de laïcité mais il combattent
un monothéisme en l'occurrence l'islam
enfin il a un discours très clair sur le
sujet or dès qu'il est il arrive
à l'Élysée
cet espace justement qui était occupé
Manuel Valls et qui opposait les deux
hommes reste vacants et donc comme la
nature a horreur du vide à ce moment là
des personnes tentent effectivement sans
qu'on peut utiliser aucun par des jeux
de réseau politique enfin comme ça
arrive dans toutes les sphères
politiques tentent effectivement de
rencontrer des personnes qui sont
proches des manuellement Macron de
rencontrer des nouveaux députés et qui
sont des personnes qui arrivent à
l'Assemblée et donc arrivent ce que nous
avons qualifié d'offensive à l'époque
qui par ailleurs a réussi c'est ce qui
s'est passé en fait il y a eu un virage
ce que l'Elysée a appelé en 2019-2020 un
virage républicain ce sont leurs mots il
y a eu ce virage là moi j'aurais pas
qualifié ça comme ça mais ils l'ont
qualifié comme ça et de fait le fond
Marianne prouve que ces personnes sont
arrivées dans l'écosystème macroniste
votre avis là-dessus elle me fero est-ce
que est-ce que ça doit pour autant ça
rejoint ce que disait jean-garis tout à
l'heure
je sais pas quelle expression employer
mais
évaluer ou démonétiser la parole de ce
courant de penser qui
issue de la gauche et présent dans le
macronisme aujourd'hui sont deux
questions très différentes il peut y
avoir des visions différentes de la
laïcité on voit l'évolution en effet
d'Emmanuel Macron entre son discours
avant son élection en 2017 et puis
quelques années plus tard
et puis il y a la mise en oeuvre ce que
vous disiez
la commission d'enquête ne se situe pas
sur le sujet de esquive fallait ou pas
lancer le fond Marianne d'ailleurs il y
a d'accord mais on y reviendra sur la
commission d'enquête mais moi ça
m'intéresse d'avoir votre avis de de
sénateurs socialiste sur sur cette
question qui parce que défendent la
laïcité en France ça me semble être un
enjeu majeur et si les conséquences de
cette affaire c'est qu'il y a de moins
en moins de voix qui s'expriment pour la
défendre est-ce qu'on n'est pas face à
un échec collectif ce serait dramatique
mais ça ne s'est pas le la révélation du
problème aujourd'hui le problème c'est
bien que c'est pas ce que nous dit d'une
certaine façon elle nous dit que c'est
peut-être un peu l'émanation de ce cours
est-ce que c'est le scandale de la ici
auquel on assiste nous avons reçu aussi
au Sénat aux commissions d'enquête des
représentants d'associations qui ont été
financés par le fond Marianne et qui ne
sont absolument pas mis en cause sur
leurs actions et l'utilité de leur
action et la réalité de leur action non
au contraire c'est justement une
ministre visiblement qui a lancé à grand
renfort de communication mais qui
derrière je crois qu'avec l'utiliser
l'expression elle-même celle que vous
utilisiez tout à l'heure je n'ai pas
soulever le capot je crois qu'elle l'a
utilisé dans son audition donc il n'a
pas suivi politiquement quand c'est
aussi sensible il faut avoir aussi le
souci de le faire
parfaitement ou en tout cas très bien et
visiblement il y a eu ensuite après la
communication un grand
désintérêt mais je pense pas que on
puisse dire au prétexte que il faut pas
jeter le bébé avec l'eau d'humain qu'on
a rien vu que c'est pas grave et qu'on
mette à l'envers là on est bien d'accord
ne confondons ne confondons pas nos
confondons pas les deux champs du sujet
Sonia baquet c'est le cas succédé à
Marlène Schiappa au ministère et qui
était auditionné cet après-midi de par
la commission d'enquête du Sénat elle
disait que d'autres associations Jean
garrigue aider par ce fonds Marianne
vous les évoquez tout à l'heure sont
aujourd'hui menacés sur les réseaux
sociaux oui donc ça c'est important de
le dire aussi et de dire qu'il faut
continuer de les aider oui j'en témoigne
pour en connaître quelques-uns je sais
que ils vivent difficilement ces
accusations ce sont des ce que je
connais en tout cas sont des personnes
intègres on peut parler de laïcisme moi
je parle de laïcité dans l'héritage de
d'Aristide Briand et de la loi de 1905
était une loi de tolérance et je pense
que tout simplement il mène une lutte
contre le séparatisme communautarisme je
pense que c'est une lutte légitime je
sais que certains dans la dans la bulle
médiatique considère que l'IS
respectable j'avais entendu ça sur la
plume d'une d'une journaliste non je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il y a un véritable
enjeu de société très important pour
maintenir ce vivre ensemble cette
citoyenneté qui est la nôtre
effectivement c'est un enjeu républicain
moi je ce terme ne me dérange pas et je
le répète manifestement il s'est passé
qu'on a eu une ministre qui aime un peu
trop la communication et qui a fait les
choses comme il fallait pas les faire
n'a pas suivi son dossier qui a mal géré
son dossier qui peut-être je le répète a
favoriser un certain nombre de ces de
ses amis mais sur le fond des choses je
pense que c'est un combat légitime et et
surtout qu'il faut ménager ceux qui le
mène de manière je dirais légale
objective et engagée pardon je pense
qu'on est tous d'accord en fait pour
dire que la laïcité est un combat
légitime le fait que il y avait un
organisme gouvernemental qui s'appelle
l'Observatoire de la laïcité qui menait
depuis des années avec le soutien le
soutien de beaucoup de terrain contestés
par effectivement les mêmes personnes
que nous retrouvons dans le fond
Marianne mais soutenu par beaucoup
d'acteurs de terrain auprès desquels ils
travaillaient quotidiennement cette
observateur de la laïcité qui pour le
coup a fait l'objet aussi de ciblage sur
les réseaux sociaux de la part des mêmes
personnes dont nous parlons a
étonnamment disparu au printemps 2021
quand le fond Marianne quand le fond
Marianne était présent ce qui est
intéressant et là c'est là où la
politique rejoint si vous voulez
l'argent si je peux me permettre c'est
que le fonctionnement annuel de
l'observateur de la laïcité c'était
59000 euros d'accord en dehors de quatre
salaires qui étaient payés 59000 euros
là on parle de 2,5 millions d'euros qui
ont été ventilés pour 408 alors je ne
sais pas en fait qui défend les valeurs
de la République et de la laïcité dans
ce genre de cas tout ce que je sais
c'est que dans le débat intellectuel
autour de la laïcité beaucoup de voix
cet été élevé pour contester la vision
de cette observatoire de la laïcité
Jean-Louis Bianco etc donc voilà moi je
prends pas position là dessus
ma petite idée sur ce que sur cela la
manière dont il faut mener ce combat et
et les complaisances qu'on peut ou ne
pas avoir ou ne pas avoir mais
simplement vous avez raison sur le plan
comptable moi je trouvais d'ailleurs que
les fonds de
cette subvention pour les fonds
Mariannes était excessif qu'on peut très
bien combattre au nom de la laïcité sans
dépenser des sommes folles mais il faut
il faut reconnaître aussi que si vous
allez sur les réseaux sociaux voyez de
quelle manière ceux qui défendent la
laïcité aujourd'hui sont décrié sont
jetés en pâture et il faut aussi les
défendre bon chacun a pu donner son avis
sur cette question que savait exactement
la ministre est évidemment une question
centrale écouter et vous ne l'avez dit
c'est un peu parole contre parole hein
ce sentiment qu'on a en suivant la
commission d'enquête écouter son
directeur de cabinet justement devant
les les sénateurs c'était il y a une
semaine
ce que je peux confirmer c'est que il y
a bien une volonté de la ministre et du
cabinet de pouvoir
décider valider l'emploi des crédits du
wifi donc il y a bien une volonté de
la ministre du cabinet de pouvoir
décider valider l'emploi des crédits du
fond on est vraiment au cœur du dossier
Mathieu c'est une audition celle de
Marlène Schiappa qui va laisser des
traces dans son parcours politique
au même moment sur l'épreuve de
philosophie pendant trois heures ce
matin Marlène Schiappa a fait sienne la
célèbre maxime socratique je sais que je
ne sais rien et pour répondre à votre
question Thomas j'ai envie de vous
répondre bah nous on sait maintenant que
son avenir politique et est très
compréhendé alors personne s'attend à
l'avoir romaine sa démission demain que
ce soit de son propre chef ou sur
injonction de la première ministre après
tout nous en sommes qu'au début de
l'affaire qu'il faut désormais clichés
de scandale à mon avis et dans le volet
judiciaire commence tout juste une de
nous en tiendrons donc juste à son
impact politique et pour le coup
celui-ci est si calamiteux qu'on ne voit
pas comment cette fidèle des premières
heures du macronisme pourrait survivre à
un remaniement alors kilos pourquoi
parce que la secrétaire d'État à
l'économie sociale et solidaire et à la
vie associative c'est son titre
aujourd'hui et ressorti à mes yeux
laminés de son audition devant les
sénateurs il a été mise en difficulté à
plusieurs reprises on l'a dit elle n'a
pas dévié de sa stratégie de défense
j'ai lancé l'idée mais je me suis pas
occupé de la suite ce défaut sans les
grammant sur un fusible déjà grillé
Christian Gravel le préfet qui était en
charge du CI du CI PDR pardon
excusez-moi ça c'était la semaine
dernière mais aussi sur ce qui est plus
nouveau et tout aussi élégant sur son
cabinet comme ça a été souligné c'est
vrai qu'on a des versions très
contradictoires or cette prétendue
ignorance de ce qu'il a bien pu advenir
de ce son Marianne prétendu par par
Marlène Schiappa c'est traduit malgré
les au mieux par un aveu d'incompétence
avec un S j'ai envie de dire s'il vous
plaît vous soyez toujours un truc est-ce
qu'on se dit est-ce qu'il vaut mieux
paraître nul ou malhonnête politiquement
c'est de toute façon un jeu perdant ou
perdant je ferai pas ici la liste des
incompétences ce serait trop long temps
la description abracadabrantesque que
Marlène Schiappa a fait du mode de
fonctionnement de son cabinet destiné en
creux une véritable pétaudière j'ai pas
d'autres mots s'il fallait qu'un cet
exemple ce serait celui-ci celui dont
vous avez parlé quand elle découvre le
projet d'attribution de 300.000 euros à
l'association de Mohamed Sifaoui la
ministre s'en estonne dans un mail ça
lui paraît énorme ici et au-delà des
dates que croyez-vous qu'il arriva
est-ce qu'elle a été suivie est-ce
qu'elle s'en soucie mais que nenni le
comité de sélection l'a dit ou siège
trois lampes de son cabinet optera au
final pour un montant encore plus élevé
de 350 5000 euros 55000 euros la
ministre dit c'est énorme ici et les
membres de son cabinet allez on remet
55000 euros par dessus enfin genre là on
freeze l'incompétence et j'utilisais
tout cela aussi un problème probablement
de décence est-ce qu'elle a encore le
soutien de les effectif elle a été
soutenue du bout des lèvres dimanche par
la première ministre mais qui est elle
aussi en sursis donc c'est dire mais au
gouvernement comme au sommet de l'État
beaucoup ne la supportent plus ingérable
incontrôlable en fait les coups d'éclats
qu'on fait sa marque de fabrique hier
avait déjà largement entamé son crédit
avant l'addition de ce matin
avoir du mal à relever son nuage parce
que c'est pas son bilan family au
secrétariat d’état à l'économie sociale
et solidaire qui pourra quelque chose ni
ces dernières interviews qu'à l'accordé
appelé Boy ou à closer c'est à vous dire
aussi le niveau de portée politique du
combat de Marlène Schiappa bref elle
devrait avoir bientôt tout le temps
nécessaire pour réfléchir peut-être au
deuxième tome de son avant dernier
best-seller vous savez ce que c'est quoi
le titre déjà c'est une bonne situation
ça d'être ministre pour effectivement
méditer ça je voudrais qu'on vienne sur
la question de ce que la ministre savait
Rémi Féraud en sortant de l'audition
qu'est-ce que vous vous êtes dit elle
dit plusieurs fois je ne suis pas
omnisciente elle est pas hyper en tout
cas donc
voilà on peut parfois en douter j'ai été
impressionné par la précision des
questions qui lui était posée par
président Claude Raynal par le
rapporteur de la commission
Jean-François Husson et puis je pense
comme tout le monde par le côté très
évasif
de ces réponses tout d'un coup c'était
plus la Marlène siapa qui c'est tout et
qui va révolutionner le monde donc
c'était voilà vraiment très très
frappant
c'était peut-être une façon de ne pas
mentir sans dire tout ce dont elle se
souvenait je ne peux pas en juger en
tout cas c'est frappant ce qui m'a
frappé aussi c'est
contradiction très précise avec ce qui a
été déclaré soit par Christian Gravel
soit par son ancien
directeur directeur de cabinet et puis
le côté irresponsabilité politique que
j'ai lancé le fond Marianne d'ailleurs
prit que il avait été décidé dans un
conseil de défense je crois que le son
lancement ce qui à mon avis et déjà
enfin pourquoi y a-t-il besoin de le
lancer dans une instance qui est secrète
on a besoin de davantage de démocratie
et de délibération pour qu'il y ait
aussi derrière du contrôle et le fait
que il n'y ait eu derrière aucun
véritable pilotage poétique de la mise
en oeuvre de ces actions d'ailleurs il
n'y a pas eu de bilan d'étape réaliser
autant que je me souvienne question n'a
pas été posée mais il n'y a pas eu de
communication de Marlène Schiappa six
mois après un an après il y a eu comme
souvent c'est le cas une dévélations par
la presse d'abord par le journal
Marianne puis assez longtemps après je
crois par Mediapart donc et France 2
donc c'est quand même il y a le process
peut être aussi très instructif pour
d'autres voilà d'autres actions
publiques qui seront menées plus tard
parce que justement la lutte contre la
radicalisation quelque chose de trop
grave et de trop sensible pour qu'il
soit pas mené très sérieusement Jean
Gary pour l'instant alors effectivement
il y a ce flou artistique entre tenu par
la ministre mais sinon c'est un peu
parole contre parole ce que disait
Hélène tout à l'heure il y a quelqu'un
qui a menti devant la commission
d'enquête c'est une vieille pouvoir et
les politiques historiquement toujours
eu tendance à reporter à se défausser
sur les fusibles en directeur de cabine
etc on l'a vu dans quasiment toutes les
affaires de dysfonctionnement comme ça
de la de la décision publique là
manifestement c'est exactement ce
qu'elle dit monsieur le sénateur c'est à
dire que on a vu dans cette commission
de quelle manière
cette cette c'est fond Marianne avait
été traitée avec beaucoup de légèreté et
d'incompétence par par cette ministre et
on peut se demander si effectivement la
surcommunication ne tue pas l'efficacité
de la gouvernance en l'occurrence on a
presque on a c'est un exemple
caricatural de ce qu'il ne faut pas
faire quand on est quand on est en
responsabilité et comme effectivement
l'enjeu me semble-t-il et majeur ça n'en
joue très important on est d'autant plus
déçu par ce qui se vient de se produire
qu'est-ce qui peut se passer maintenant
il y a d'autres enquête en cours et la
commission d'enquête du Sénat qui qui va
se terminer il y a notamment l'enquête
du parquet national financier
Marlène Schiappa a pas été encore
entendue par les par les enquêteurs de
parquet d'accord ça ça va être une étape
importante et des perquisitions hier
dans des dans au domicile de plusieurs
acteurs du dossier dont Mohamed cifaoui
dont le préfet Gravel
et l'enquête suit son cours il y aura
fin juin aussi un nouveau rapport de
l'Inspection Générale d'administration
qui cette fois-ci s'éteindra aux autres
associations on peut avoir une espèce de
carte postale d'images globale de la
gestion du fond et simplement pour pour
rebondir
aux deux autres invités il y a je trouve
une question éminemment politique et
celle-ci elle ne se règlera ni devant
les tribunaux ni devant la commission
d'enquête ni même par l'Inspection
générale de l'administration c'est c'est
quoi être une ministre en fait justement
est-ce que c'est une bonne situation à
être ministre être ministre être
responsable politique c'est savoir que
dans le mot responsable politique il y a
le mot responsable et en fait c'est
quelque chose visiblement qui a été trop
longtemps oublié alors peut-être
historiquement il y a eu toujours des
fusibles et les responsables politiques
se sont toujours dit qu'il y avait
quelqu'un qui méritait davantage de
partir que avant la vérité c'est ce qui
a émané de l'édition de ce matin c'est
que on avait quelqu'un au ministère de
l'intérieur on n'est pas n'importe où on
est place Beauvau
ministère de l'Intérieur
et une administration importante lourdes
et là on avait quelqu'un qui est en
clair nous expliquer que elle ne savait
pas qu'elle n'avait rien vu rien entendu
qu'elle avait lancé une communication et
que finalement c'était son rôle mais
qu'en dehors du compte Twitter et d'un
plateau de télévision tout le reste ça
la regardait pas politiquement c'est
énorme d'avoir une ministre qui dit que
l'administration placé sous sa tutelle
le cabinet placé sous sa responsabilité
ont été en autogestion pendant des
années c'est vrai que dans d'autres pays
notamment anglo-saxon il y a des
ministres qui démissionnent beaucoup
plus vite que que chez nous dernier mot
la commission d'enquête ça dure jusqu'à
quand et qu'est ce qu'il en ressort on
fait un peu de pédagogie parlementaire
ici aussi vous verrez non non qu'est-ce
qui peut peser après avec les
conclusions d'une commission d'enquête
ah bah l'établissement de d'un certain
nombre de vérité parce que les gens
parlaient sous serment d'un certain
nombre de contradictions et des
responsabilités
d'ailleurs
Marlène sia pas peut dire c'est pas moi
c'est trois membres de mon cabinet mais
pour un ministre trois membres de son
cabinet et c'est sa responsabilité donc
voilà sa façon de parler de son cabinet
était très étonnante ce qu'il en
ressortira je veux pas comme ça
anticiper sur les émissions sont pas
terminées
un certain nombre aussi j'espère
d'enseignements pour la conduite de ce
genre d'appel à projet et de suivi
derrière des règles Marlène sia pas à 10
qui n'est pas vrai il n'y a pas de règle
pour l'attribution de subventions
je trouvais ça d'ailleurs étrange
qu'elle le disque comme ça et peut-être
que il faut davantage précisé les choses
pour les appels à projets mais d'abord
la commission d'enquête elle établira
une quand même des chaînes de
responsabilité et savoir ce qui s'est
passé donc elle devrait le faire assez
rapidement puisque elle devrait le faire
avant la pose de l'été justement c'est
ce qui a permis une commission d'enquête
rapide qui est la commission des
finances du Sénat merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat Jean Gary je
rappelle le titre de votre livre Elysée
contre Matignon qui est publié aux
éditions tallendier merci encore et à
bientôt sur public